foreign
[Music]
yeah so am I it's a crazy Place damn it
it's so much energy so much energy lots
of uh lots of Dancing Yeah Yeah I'm not
dancing on Tick Tock if I dance at all
it's the moonwalk and that's it that's
all I'm giving all right that's all I'm
giving you so someone once asked me or
commented on that they didn't want
people to be afraid of turbulence on an
airplane and they wanted you to know
that the airplane moving in turbulence
is not any different from sort of like
uh the the fruit that would be in the in
jello right because all the air moves
together and it just moves the fruit
with it and so you shouldn't worry that
the whole airplane is going to break
apart I I'm just gonna say
um
I understand that premise
and it doesn't comfort me at all okay
okay so so okay so I so I I reflected on
this in my reply but I thought I'd tell
you because I don't want meat I don't
want all the good secrets to only Land
one place without the benefit of you
hearing them because I I appreciate it I
so much enjoy your feedback and every
time I see a plane crash I will think oh
look at that somebody dropped the jello
so I kind of made that same point if the
turbulence
if the turbulent cell is larger than the
airplane all right than the entire
airplane will move with the turbulence
and not rip off the wings okay
however however there it is however
there we go if you have enough if you
you know it's coming if you have if the
if the the size scale of the turbulent
pockets is smaller than the airplane
then the airplane itself will get
torqued out of any way it wants to be
with One Wing being flipped upwards or
downwards or or the middle up or down
the front versus the back the tail fin
and so uh that would be very stressful
on the airplane right and in this Tech
talk the person said everything is fine
in turbulence
um you can say that for the planes that
survived but you can't interview anyone
who's dead on the ground about the
turbulence that did not take out the
airplane
yep that's all I'm saying there so now
in addition
it's one thing to move the little piece
of fruit in the jello by the way who
still makes that dish that's very 1966
right apparently the person who made
that Tick Tock was in a nursing home
when they did so
[Laughter]
all right so here's the thing so
obviously the the peach cubes are
smaller than the total jiggle Factor not
a problem okay however
turbulence is moving the airplane
when you're going through this
turbulence okay okay and the airplane
has an airfoil that is responding to the
moving air
are we together I'm with you okay if you
are in that airplane
but you're not attached to the airplane
uh-huh then the airplane can move around
you that's right unlike the fruit in the
jelly unlike the fruit in the jello so
now what you need to do is think about
the fruit in the jello
instead of being supported by the jello
it it just has a small apartment inside
inside the bridge out okay and you've
got table settings and things you're
sitting around with your water for the
crystal that you just put down because
it's having a fancy meal because some
other Peach cubes are coming over right
there little pocket in the jello right
right and so you shake the jello okay
the peach cubes flies up and hits the
its head on the ceiling of your Jello
pocket okay
so if you're not attached to the plane
the plane can drop in elevation yes
faster than your body will respond and
you'll snap your neck on the ceiling of
the plane that's right okay yeah just
saying here so that's why when they
enter turbulence the pilot gets on is
that uh passengers we need you to put on
your seatbelt because when you put them
another plane
this is your captain speaking just want
to let you know that we're in for a
little bit of a bumpy ride ahead uh well
so nothing to be worried about but if
you do believe in God now's yourself
this would be the ideal time to kiss
your ass goodbye
make peace with your maker and kiss your
ass goodbye all right so you put on your
seat belt and what does that then do
based on all the the language I've been
using thus far what does that do it ties
you to the jello thank you it makes you
part of the airplane so when the
airplane Jiggles up and down you're
moving with the jello that's right so uh
so that's that's the only Point here
that I want to make about you being
jiggling in inside of a gel now we hear
about these Brave folks who are flying
airplanes into hurricanes crazy
no Noah has a Noah the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration has
special airplanes just for this purpose
okay right they fly into a hurricane and
you say oh my gosh you know here's the
here's why you think hurricanes would be
bad for airplanes okay it's because you
see the effects of hurricanes on
stationary objects right on the ground
you see the effect of a hurricane on
your roof on the gas station canopy on
the boats okay
the air
on a category five hurricane is moving
200 miles an hour in a circle
you're playing most planes going 500
miles an hour okay so you can take your
plane
fly 200 miles an hour adjacent to it
step into the moving air and now you're
now you can just you're getting a little
bit of a a boost getting a boost now you
can go 500 miles an hour relative to the
Earth 250 miles an hour relative to the
hurricane okay and you just in the air
you make your measurements and then you
come out and you're fine look at that so
it's just not as hazardous as you might
think unless while you're in the
airplane you see like Dorothy's house or
something I was gonna say yeah with
debris
you get hit with a cow you know
one you're flying too low or two man
this is a hell of a hurricane
holy right if you see Darcy and Auntie M
right right
so it's why the plane is the safest
thing you could be a part of that's why
seat belts matter on an airplane that's
all and so what about so I I'm sure at
some point during the uh our aviation
history planes were not
constructed to withstand turbulence air
pockets in fact you know what they did
until recently until they trusted
computer simulations of the airplane you
just invented there's something called
there's a there's a in the stage of
every brand new airplane
um they want you to bend the wings until
they break
okay so they have the claim the
Prototype plane and they put it in the
hangar and they attach these these these
uh the cables to the wing tips okay and
they hold down the airplane and they
start lifting up the tips
and they're measuring what angle how
high up the tip can go
until the tip completely breaks the wing
off the airplane
and that's an important measurement for
how much turbulence the plane can
withstand where the turbulent pockets
are smaller than the plane itself right
now we have very good simulations of the
metal and stress points and I think
today they're allowing them to submit
computer simulations of the breakage
points but you've been on an airplane
looked out the window and see the wings
look like they're flapping right when
it's really windy and turbulent you've
seen this wow I was I was on a dragon
honestly
so you trained Your Dragon yeah right so
so the wingtip it Jiggles and it looks
like oh my gosh it's going to break off
right but no they've tested it Way
Beyond the normal
turbulent conditions under which you
would ever experience in a flight on
your own it's kind of like um struts and
shock absorbers in a car you you you can
hit a pothole and you just keep on going
but there's always that one pothole that
breaks your A-frame and then you're just
like oh damn Yeah well yeah but the good
thing about that is that you're still on
the ground I was going to say they don't
have AAA in sky right right right right
a car whose engine fails is just
something that Glides off the side of
the road and airplane whose engine fails
is a is a glider uh if it's a yeah it's
a brick right you got to watch out for
that you know you said that once before
because I we were talking about this was
years ago but we're talking about I took
a plane ride with uh his uh I don't know
if he's an astrophist he's a physicist a
serious that's the name of the plane has
a parachute in it
and yeah it's really cool but you know
first of all let me just say that did
not Inspire confidence in me when he
told me while we're up in the air oh you
know that uh This Plane actually has a
parachute in it it's like one parachute
not two okay well the parachute is for
the whole plane oh yeah the plane itself
has a pla apparent that is low
confidence in your own engineering
wow but um
um
um he said something to me about flying
uh while we were up there I said um so
what do you what do you think about
helicopters because he he's like
Aviation nut
and he was like well
I I I really don't appreciate
helicopters because they don't as much
fly as they do beat the air into
submission
very good yeah so Chuck we gotta wrap it
there okay a turbulence in the air nice
what he's saying is that the helicopter
creates turbulence right and yeah
whatever he's like that's not flight
it's like basically it's you know it's
using turbulence as a way to stay a stay
afloat if you will actually if the wings
are properly designed it's a laminar
flow rather the turbulence is an actual
official term right fluid dynamics that
you don't want something to be turbulent
it's hardly ever good in your situation
for airflow to be turbulent that's a
laminar
I like that
flow yeah lamina means it's the air
flows in layers smoothly over the
surface and the air Puck the Air does
not leave the surface of the object it's
moving on because if it does then it
creates a partial vacuum and then air
just rapidly goes into that partial
vacuum that's when you see that Earl
Sweat the air swirling correct that's
turbulence you don't want that right you
don't want that right yeah but usually
it creates drag on what you're doing
right and laminar flow is like a cool
cool I'm waiting to hear that in a rap
song
I'm telling you right no no it's a new
age song laminar Flow yeah but it's
rappers are always talking about their
flow so yeah it's just like the rhythm
of the Rhymes you know y'all gotta
respect my laminar flow like you know
something like that that sucked but you
know what I'm saying no that was good
that was one spot that was good all
right dude we gotta call it quits there
that has been another explainer we're
talking about jello
uh and turbulence
only on Star top all right Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personalized for
physicist keep looking up
[Music]